this week
on brian ross investigates dangerous
setbacks
in the fight against covet 19 a powerful
new strain of the virus
and deadly delays in the long-awaited
vaccinations
how did this happen we're joined by the
former acting surgeon general
dr boris lushniak to get some answers
plus will this be the year of reckoning
powerful church leader
accused of the rape and sex trafficking
of young girls in his worldwide
congregation
the woman who's accused of helping groom
his victims after first being a victim
herself
now wants the world to know what really
happens behind the altar
and in the secret tunnels and rooms of
the light of the world church
she was eight years old when she was
first raped by samwell who is the
current apostle's father the former
apostle
and this week's winners and losers in
the media
including the reporter who first
revealed the stunning tape
of the president's phone call asking
georgia officials
to throw the election his way i just
want to find
11 11 780
votes from the law and crime trial
network
this is brian ross investigates
good evening and thank you for joining
us and welcome to our viewers on
facebook live
i'm brian ross joined tonight as always
by my colleague rhonda schwartz and
rhonda
it's a new year a year which could be a
year of reckoning for yet another
powerful man
accused of abusing young women under his
authority and control
he calls himself the apostle nasa
joaquin garcia
leads the light of the world church
which claims to have
5 million members in the united states
and in dozens of countries around the
world
his trial in california could begin in
the next few months but tonight we're
learning
there may be no charges coming against
him rhonda
that's right brian on top of the
criminal charges he faces in california
state court
nessie joaquin garcia and his light of
the world church are also under
investigation
by federal authorities in mexico and the
united states the long crime network has
learned
looking into additional allegations of
human trafficking
and accusations of improper use of
church money
related to the apostles financial
lifestyle
and rhonda his trial in california will
likely include the testimony against him
by one of his former handmaidens alondra
accapo
she has pleaded guilty to a number of
charges in a plea deal
and now she wants the world to know
although she can't yet talk publicly
but what she knows about the apostle
we're joined now
by missile campus lawyer fred phil
garaga mr
fear garage why did your client decide
to plead guilty
i think my client has actually always
wanted to
to plead guilty and she's always wanted
to basically expose the church
and the uh and the garcias for uh
their true intentions uh but there have
been certain obstacles that have
prevented that from
from taking place up until very recently
so
um you know she's being accused or she
was being accused
of dozens of
uh felony sex charges and so one can't
just
say i plead guilty to all of it um you
know some of the charges
were true some of the charges weren't
true so we
there was it took some time to sift
through and negotiate
what she could plead guilty to what she
couldn't plead guilty to if she had just
pled guilty to everything at the outset
she'd be facing over 60 years in state
prison
you say that she wants to expose the
true intentions of the apostle
what were they well
you know some people believe that this
is a uh
that this is a church and maybe you know
a small part of it
is engaged in uh the sort of rampant
sexual abuse and pedophilia
but there may be more sinister
intentions here i think
that uh there's been generations of
pedophilia that have existed within this
church
from the founder all the way down to the
its current version of the apostle
nasan joaquin maybe you know
this is really a pedophilia ring that's
been disguised as a church
um you know or maybe it's a church
but these uh successive generations of
apostles have discovered
that it's also you know they can engage
in their sort of deviant sexual
behaviors
within the guise of the church uh but
for whatever
whichever it is um you know it's quite
clear that uh three generations of
garcias have been engaging
in rampant um sexual abuse and
pedophilia
um and lately uh child pornography
um and so and and yet they maintain this
this image
of of holiness and purity um
and you know so people are now starting
to
starting to see them for what they are
and
my client mrs acapo wants to play a role
in that she wants to expose them
and and actually one of the reasons
she's asked me to be her spokesperson is
is
she wants to hopefully uh
prevent these abuses from occurring to
other women um
it took her a long time to realize that
what was being done to her
uh was not holy was not righteous
uh was not something mandated by
god and she's hoping that other
women who are or were in the same
situation she was in will
will see this and um
hopefully we'll learn that this abuse
isn't right
how old was she when she was first
abused she was
eight years old when she was first raped
by um samwell who is the
current apostles father the former
apostle
eight years old yes uh
it was during a it was in guadalajara
it was during a time in which it was a
um
a very it was a religious ceremony of
some kind
where people from all over the world
would come and gather
at the the church buildings uh
and um grounds in guadalajara
there are secret tunnels and rooms that
are underneath
the the church buildings so there are
tunnels that connect the buildings
uh and there are secret rooms um
that are uh connected to these tunnels
and she was taken to one of these rooms
and there she was met by um
nissan samwell at the time was the
apostle
and he told her that she had been
selected
to be his bride and did that abuse the
sexual abuse continue on a regular basis
then from age eight on
yes uh it continued it was continuous
and she's being told by the voice of god
that this is
this is you know that this is uh what
what is happening is a holy thing
uh and that this is her way to heaven
and
and that she cannot tell anyone and so
by that time she was so conditioned
into you know just believing whatever
whatever it was that was told to her
and accepting that that what was being
done to her was a blessing this was her
belief
um for for many many years that what
she had what had been done to her wasn't
actually
abuse her perception was this was a
blessing
bestowed upon her by the apostle so she
went from being abused to being a
recruiter in a way then of other young
girls
yes uh and i think this is you know
certainly something that
is not uncommon
um we see it in other types of
trafficking cases where
uh you know children or women young
women who've been groomed
or trafficked then turn on later on
become
you know assisters or aiders and bettors
of the people who do the trafficking
but yes she was abused all her life
and then later on she was
coerced into grooming and when naison
joaquin asked her to
assist him part of
part of the reason she obeyed him is
because she has been conditioned her
entire life
into obeying the apostle just like every
member of this church
and every member of her family she's not
prepared to testify against the apostle
in his criminal trial if she
is a subpoenaed as a witness and i and i
believe she will be um but if she is
subpoenaed as a witness by the
government
uh then yes she is prepared to testify
um
to the truth as to all the things that
um happen to her and all the things that
she had been forced to do
and what will she admit as to her own
culpability her own wrongdoing
well she has pled guilty to four felony
counts
um i should let you know that the terms
of the plea bargain
are under seal so there are some things
that i
i cannot reveal to you by order of court
but she did plead guilty to four crimes
those three of those crimes involve
basically
having contact with a minor in order to
facilitate
a sex crime what's her frame of mind is
she remorseful is she relieved
what is she thinking now she sits
waiting time where she'll make a plea of
her guilt and
perhaps testify against the apostle the
man who she was taught to
believe uh blindly
it's one of relief i think uh certainly
and there's a mix of emotions here
but relief is certainly one of them and
there's definitely remorse um you know
if she
it's complicated even in in the remorse
because
she she knows that she has done bad
things
um and part of it is she
you know it's what has been forced upon
her
and part of it is what has been
conditioned into her
but nevertheless you know as a society
we still expect her to accept some
responsibility
for these things and she herself
is is remorseful and sad that other
women have gone through what she has
gone through
and and she wants to help all right fred
fia garager the attorney for orlando
akapo thank you so much for being here
today with us
giving us this rare insight to what's
happening inside that church and
inside the life of the apostle thanks
for being here tonight
thank you brian coming up next where are
those vaccines
what can be done to speed up the
snail-paced delivery
of the much-needed coven 19 vaccinations
when we come back
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the long crime trial network
back now with the daily death vote from
covet 19 setting grim
records and the lag in the delivery of
the vaccinations the question is what's
going on what's going to happen
we're joined by dr boris lushniak the
former acting surgeon general in the
united states and now
head of the school of public health at
the university of maryland
dr lushnyak where are those vaccinations
where are the vaccines
well right now there's not a whole lot
of them uh
you know they've been put into uh the
places where they need to be stored
appropriately and as you know the
problem with these vaccines is that they
need to be kept at rather cold
temperatures
the big problem is that they are not
getting where they need to get into and
that is into people
right into people's arms and there's
been a breakdown
i think a large extent in terms of
settling the logistics of how do you
move it
not only from the place of manufacturing
right that's been done
by by transportation uh experts
uh but how do you move it from where
they're being stored to appropriately
give it
the high-risk groups that need to get it
right now and that's where the breakdown
is occurring
uh and there needs to be a reconciling
of whose responsibility
is it to make sure it gets to the people
we thought with operation warp speed all
of that was being planned ahead but now
we see the president
telling the governors is up to them and
in new york at least the governor's
blaming the mayor and the mayor's
blaming the hospitals the fingers are
being pointed
everywhere how do we get out of this
situation to get rid of this sluggish
delivery of these much needed
vaccinations
well it's going to take leadership and
leadership at the national level
working directly with the state and
local authorities on this
it can't be as simple as blaming people
saying well i gave it to you
right whether it's the feds telling the
states well i gave it to you do
something about it
this is an undertaking a massive
undertaking that we
as a society have not done right we've
never done this type of vaccination
effort to try to achieve 80 of our
population getting a vaccine has never
been done in the united states
so one because we've not done this there
could be some growing pains as we're
seeing right now
the key feature right now is leadership
needs to be looking at what's working
what's not working and how do you
reconcile what's not working
and that starts at the federal level and
is done
with direct communication at the state
and local level whose responsibility
is to do what when
dr lashniak a question for you from
rhonda schwartz rhonda
with the discovery of a new variation on
the coronavirus
in london they're now under draconian
lockdown that's supposed to extend
through
february how much worse is it there and
is that likely to happen here
you know it's uncertain we first of all
expect
there to be mutations of the virus this
is what virus
particles do right there's changes in
their genetics
the disconcerting factor of what was
found in england but probably was
already occurring in other places we
know we've seen
this this mutation in south africa we've
seen it in the few states here in the
united states
is what is number one that the seams the
initial data seem to prove that this new
mutation
is much more infectious so the spread of
this virus will be easier between person
and person
if in fact this mutation kind of takes
over if you will
so there is concern and the reality is
we have to monitor what's going on
both in england in terms of their
methodologies right they're going more
towards a lockdown scenario which is
keep people away from each other as much
as possible
uh to a higher level and see what
happens there
here in the united states we have
unfortunately limited
information because we're not doing a
whole lot of testing of the virus for
these
genetic changes right for these
mutations
so we don't know a lot in terms of
what's going on in the united states we
got to get better at in terms of the
science
here and utilizing science to determine
what mutations are out there
but yeah this is a matter of concern
which does change
the the scenario to a large extent in
terms of this being much more infectious
so it's difficult to predict how this is
going to change things uh
but we have to be prepared for
tougher methods
and dr lakshnik finally what's the
optimistic look where you see the bright
side here
so the bright side first of all public
health we have to be yeah we have to be
optimists right
uh people in public health who are
pessimists get get washed out early on
in their careers and i've had a good
career
uh that being said uh the optimism here
is what is
number one that we're going to get our
act together in terms of the logistics
and getting this
where it needs to be as i mentioned into
people's arms
number two that production of the
current uh
emergency use authorized the vaccines
continues to increase
and in fact that we have additional
vaccines added
to the weaponry against this virus
uh and when i look at optimism as i tell
my students at the university of
maryland next semester is going to be a
whole lot like last semester
next summer i believe is going to be
different than last summer and it's
going to be better so that's my optimism
because we'll get
our act together in terms of a public
health response in terms of vaccines
getting there
as long as people still keep following
the
the recommendations and this is again a
plea to your
your viewers here keep wearing the mask
stay away from others as much as
possible wash your hands
that doesn't go away with a vaccine
once again doctor boris lucknock with
some wise words thank you so much again
for joining us in this new year
appreciate it very much
thank you much
coming up this week's winners and losers
in the media
including the reporter from the
washington post who first revealed those
trump telephone call tapes you're
watching brian ross investigates on the
law and crime
trial network
time now for this week's winners and
losers in the media the first of the
year as chosen by the editors of
mediaite
and we're joined by aidan mclaughlin who
is the editor-in-chief of midiite which
like the law and crime
trial network is part of the dan abrams
media empire aiden happy new year thanks
for joining us
your first winner this year amy gardner
a reporter for the washington post
many of our viewers never heard of her
but she's been doing great work
including this weekend she discovered
and revealed for the first time the
tapes of president trump's phone call
to georgia officials
what they did and you're not reporting
it that's a you know that's a
criminal that's a criminal offense and
and you know you can't let that happen
that's
that's a big risk to you and to ryan
your lawyer that's a big risk so
look all i want to do is this i just
want to find
uh 11
hundred and eighty votes which is one
more that we have
because we won the state
aiden it was an astounding phone call
and great work by the reporter for the
washington post
that's right so what you were just
listening to there is president donald
trump
basically berating georgia election
officials
including brad raffensberger who is the
georgia secretary of state and his legal
counsel
now basically those officials have told
the president repeatedly
that joe biden won their state the
president called them up
on saturday and had this private call
that mark meadows was on the line for
the chief of staff
to the president where for an hour he
basically floated a series of
false claims and conspiracy theories
about the election uh and ultimately
said
all i need to do is find 11 000 and
something votes which is the
the amount of the margin uh that joe
biden won the state by um so it was a
pretty astonishing call
and amy gardner who's a national
political reporter for the washington
post
uh ended up obtaining an audio of that
call that was recorded by these georgian
election officials
and released to her once president
donald trump started speaking up
publicly about the call and
misrepresenting it
uh so it was a huge uh scoop for this
washington post reporter
and she's been really good on the beat
of sort of uh election conspiracy
theories
uh so it's uh it's another feather in
her cap
absolutely great work as for a loser lou
dobbs of fox business
who refuses to accept any indication
that there is no evidence of crimes
committed he wonders why there is no
evidence here's what he had to say
we're uh eight weeks from the election
and we still don't have
verifiable tangible support
for the uh for the
the crimes that everyone knows were
committed
that is defrauding other
citizens who voted with fraudulent votes
we know that's the case in nevada we
know it's the case in pennsylvania
and a number of other states but we have
had a double of a time
uh finding actual proof uh why
and aidan we have just 15 seconds but
yet again lou dobbs a doubter right
i mean just it should occur to him that
the reason that there's no definitive
proof
uh to support any of these allegations
that courts are accepting that the
election was stolen
should lead you to the indication that
maybe the election wasn't stolen it's
shocking that he hasn't
achieved that realization yet while the
rest of us have
absolutely all right aidan mclaughlin
thank you so much and thanks to all of
you for joining us again for a new year
of brian ross investigates and thanks to
our great team for getting us on
and off the air successfully
[Music]
you